now let's be candid if Kaepernick's
message in his new graphic novel was
about how much he loved America how
blessed he was to have such selfless
adoptive parents
you know he wouldn't be rich and he
wouldn't have his own publishing company
or a Netflix deal
and that's the angle joining me now is
Florida Congressman Byron Donalds and
Horace Cooper co-chair of project 21
Congressman again you know Kaepernick is
just the vessel the most recent vessel
for the left you know poisonous hatred
uh that they're pouring into this
country but when adoptive parents of a
minority child get hit across the face
um again we don't know what happened in
his household
um it kind of you kind of see where this
has all taken us
I mean look Laura first things first I
mean his parents decided to adopt him
out of the goodness of their heart they
raised him part of his success being an
NFL quarterback is part of of what they
did instilling and nurturing in him in
his life I just couldn't imagine you
know doing that to somebody who raised
you you know I think about my mom like
you know my mom said a lot of tough
things to me growing up about how I'm
supposed to comport myself and carry
myself as an individual in America and
so to write a book about that I I just I
just couldn't get there and so that's
the thing that's problematic about this
because they decided to make a decision
for themselves to care for him and so in
my view to not honor them I just think
it's wrong yeah it's an anecdote and a
graphic novel about his life but Horus
the point is
um the the theme that America is racist
sells in publishing companies and
including Kaepernick's own publishing
company but it sells and by the way he
used the another interview yesterday to
display his utter contempt for the white
culture watch
two
really take hold of my blackness and do
it in a way that I was proud of and I
was excited about and the difficulty
with that is
being in white culture so it's trying to
navigate that while having a white
family and being in a predominantly
white community
and trying to find ways to make sure
that my identity and my blackness isn't
stripped from me
Horace a lot of Naval gazing going on
here
um what do you make of all of this
uh it just tells me
um racism is so awful in America that
Colin Kaepernick's little coloring book
is likely going to be a bestseller
because everybody is on the racism train
you know I look at this story of his
life and what I see is a life that many
millions of Americans would be grateful
for would find it a amazing story of the
possibilities of what makes America
here's a man who is living a life where
parents do the very kinds of things that
they do every single day we call these
loving parents to make it possible for
you to be a success if my mother and
father and my grandmother hadn't
intervened to influence me which by the
way Colin Kaepernick would probably call
them race is too even though they're all
black
I wouldn't be sitting right here today
you got Prince Harry you got call it
Colin Kaepernick two super super
privileged people complaining about how
they grew up amazing you know
Congressman donzy think of what's
happened to our inner cities especially
our schools at the hands of the party
that Kaepernick is most closely aligned
to obviously the life the Democrats
that's the real carnage in America I
mean he grew up in a privileged
Community you know good for him parents
I don't know them but gosh she seemed
like he was very appreciative of them
for most of his career but he has to
sell a book in a comic book and a
Netflix special and suddenly you know
they might as well be wearing you know
you know white hoods uh but you know
what do you what do you make of this
obsession with victimology and selling
victimology to young people is it not a
very cynical view of this country
uh it absolutely is but real quick Laura
I'm coming back to one thing I remember
my own mother talking about uh different
hairdos and hairstyles cornrows and the
like and she was like no you you can't
do that this is the way you're going to
carry yourself that's how you're going
to do your hair and all that stuff it's
gonna be nice it's going to be cut nice
and that's what you're going to do now
to the victimology from the left this is
one of the things that real cancer in
our country because the ills of our past
are what they are the Civil Rights
Movement is the thing that everybody
should study all the fights all the
struggles but to try to weaponize that
into the minds of young black kids today
who were in a far better position than
any era of black individuals in the
history of our country is outrageous and
it is a defeating proposition for these
young people because it doesn't help
them understand to fully take into
account their own agency with all the
opportunities they have in America today
I think it's destructive of the country
again where's hope and change Obama was
all about optimism and tomorrow is going
to be better than today apparently
nothing's ever going to get better under
their policies and so they just have to
stay on the uh as as Horus hauled at the
race train congressman and Horace thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else